we don't have a lot more time putzing
around we must get much more relevant
very quickly grounded in platform and
culture truths we need to leave our
insecurities and Egos and ideologies at
the door and walk into these boardrooms
and win on consumer truth
can someone here Define quality for me
if it sells the price
so that's interesting you've just real
we need to be friends immediately
I agree with that one of the absolute
things we should judge when we say
quality is does it sell the product I do
believe quality has to factor in it
achieving the mission at hand which is
to get someone to buy it I also believe
that the way quality is debated in every
boardroom in the Fortune 500 cpg
landscape is completely based on
someone's opinion if it is hitting
luxury enough funny enough irreverent
enough their personal opinion
and so I think that we must Define
quality first I think everyone here
intuitively understands if they had to
bet their children's health on it
what the tick tock would look like to
make it sk2 cell probably looks very
different than what would be approved by
everyone in here and that becomes the
debate that I would like to have because
why are we emotional about what is
relevant
relevant today luxury around the world
requires for growth to do Partnerships
with streetwear brands do you understand
25 years ago if you told Louis Vuitton
or Gucci or Hermes that they would be
doing collaboration deals with Street
kids from Queens
they would laugh you out of the room
but they got to a point where they
couldn't win on relevance enough anymore
without them
we must learn from what's happened prior
to us if you do not acquire 25 and 27
and 20 year olds who as you know every
day are requiring more and more from
their formulas so much so that our point
of differentiation on the massive
incredible formula we have continues to
close the gap
if we do not become relevant under 35
and yesterday we will all wake up and
realize that it was our era that put the
executives that are dealing with the
issues five years from now in a
pecurious spot while you are the
custodians of this iconic brand I ask
you to not put the next group in a
pecurious position
my friends we don't have a lot more time
putzing around
we must get much more relevant
very quickly grounded in platform and
culture truths
and we must allow our insecurities and
Egos and ideologies
we need to leave them at the door and
walk into these board rooms and win on
consumer truth we must we have to
challenge and we must talk to our bosses
bosses bosses with respect but with
Candor of what's actually happening with
the consumer
and you all know it
that's me you know that's the part
that's what motivates me to do stuff
like this if I can get one person in
here to just say you know what I am
going to say something in the next
meeting I don't believe that the
circulation of this magazine is actually
how many Impressions we're getting
yes
enough
I believe in marketing and branding over
everything
but measuring brand is like measuring
love measuring brand is like measuring
God I understand that you have reports
to justify it but it doesn't mean it's
true so we need to bring Common Sense
back to the table when we have media and
creative together which is a whole
nother conversation that has to happen
in this industry we must bring back
media and creative together Under One
Roof for one agency so we can hold them
accountable
because this whole game of this is doing
nothing for us the model that I believe
in is desperate to be held accountable
to business
the industry has done everything to not
be held accountable and so that's how I
would do it with brand because you know
you're affecting them not because of
discounting not because you're good
sales organization you have incredible
placement within the store it's because
you've proven that messaging has
compelled more people to buy something
than not and so that's how you would do
it thank you
oh yes thank you and I would love to
take a photo I think with everyone sure
[Music]